edwin is with us edwin's in new york
city hi edwin how can we help
hi how are you thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
all right so uh my wife and i we are on
a baby step 3b uh we're saving up for a
house
and um we were debating also disabled
for a car as well
so we had some extra saving on the side
for it but we decided not to do it
and um my in-laws i guess they knew that
we wanted to get another car because i
already have one and my in-laws
bought my uh my wife a car for her
birthday
so we were very grateful and generous
for the gift and everything
but uh we found out that they actually
had to finance the car
in order to to get it to us so we
weren't really too comfortable with that
but um i wanted to call to see what uh
what can we do next
so obviously they did not put the car in
your name or they financed it with a
personal note
yeah well no they uh the car is under
their name yeah the insurance
registration everything's on their name
yeah um nothing's on our name
yeah and they still have to pay it off
and the other thing is it's a it's a
brand new car too
but it's not like an old car it's a
brand new car oh my god um
yeah so we don't want to like we we have
the money to
we don't know what the remaining balance
is but we could assume how much it is
and we have the money to
pay it but then today it feels
to them it feels like we're taking away
from their gift to us
yeah yeah well this is not a gift this
is a curse
yeah they're just confused they're broke
people trying to do a nice thing
the wrong way and edward if you do this
you're taking money out of the home down
payment fund correct
well the thing is that we we so we had
the money aside
for the car and also for the home oh
okay but since we since we decided that
you know what we're not going to get a
call right now
right we kind of just grouped everything
together so the only
difference is going to be is i don't
know a difference of like seven months
in completing the dataset 3d
so um that big of a deal for us but i
don't know how you've got
you got serious family issues
right because normal people don't do
this this is toxic
normal people communicate adult to adult
and say we'd love to give you a car but
we're going to take us a little while to
pay it off and talk about it
instead of showing up and going
surprised we're going to give you a pony
she's not eight years old she's a grown
woman
this is toxic weird crap yeah this tries
to tell us that hey look we want to get
your car what kind of car you guys want
and we told them like hey look you know
we want to wait we don't want to call
right now we're good how we
are right now yeah i guess they just
felt like it was
i don't know like they knew best kind of
thing yeah they were demanding
they decided they were going to tell you
all what you're going to do
how does your wife feel about this
she's a little mixed about it she she
doesn't want to hurt their feelings but
she knows it's a bad deal
right yeah exactly well i think the two
of you have to decide what you're going
to do
if this happened at my house your wife
is
it's her parents she's gonna have to
handle it i mean you can sit there for
support but she's gonna have to do the
talking
mom and dad we love you and this was an
attempt to do something really nice
but it was a negative attempt and we
don't want the car
we will not accept the car and you
should take the car
back and you should sell it
and get it out of your life and then you
guys go on with your life and don't do
this again
please have better communication with us
than this
this is not how we live our lives